dominique est venu avec ses petites
filles sonia elle attend la fin du cours
de natation de ses enfants
dans les deux cas c'est un pouf réussi
dans le nouveau centre aquatique des
bêtises est à viroflay
c'est super super sympa les maîtres
nageurs sont extra d'une gentillesse
trombe
les enfants y sont aux stages de
vacances et une prescience et une fois
professionnalisme vraiment un sac idéal
c'est une vraiment une très belle
réalisation
franchement tout le monde et tout le
temps contre petits et grands après un
an et demi de travaux ce nouveau
complexe sportif a ouvert ses portes le
28 juin dernier son adresse n'a pas
changé mais les activités elles se sont
développées les piscines qu'on
construisait il ya 50 ans et c'est quand
qu'on suit maintenant n'ont rien à voir
on élargit et avec cette dimension
bien-être qui n'existaient pas ou très
peu en fait dans l'ancienne piscine et
qui permet de bénéficier d'équipements
de douches sensorielles de sauna d'un
hammam pour en fait passer un grand un
moment de détente familiale ou
individuels à laitages des activités de
relaxation et une salle de sport mais
l'atout de l'établissement c'est la
terrasse donc là on a la terrasse qui
appartient à l'espace bien-être avec
deux saunas extérieur elle est séparée
en deux une pour un espace pour le
public qui ont pris uniquement une
entrée piscine et un espace pour les
personnes qui ont accès at et espace
bien-être
c'est juste voilà c'est juste en face de
la forêt c'est voilà c'est reposant
on entend dévoiler pour il est soit on
voit là c'est cadre idéal pour profiter
de l'espace bien-être il faut débourser
16 euros 30 cantons navy rohff les yeux
18h35 pour les extérieurs
l'accès à la piscine elle se fait à
partir de 5 euros pour les habitants de
la ville